welcome to this video with juris no do
this touristy gayton know that's
probably totally wrong yeah some
probably it's got some Swedish of origin
this name again some closest Lena system
or getting into fashion why why exactly
okay so do we ought to be get here but
should be five and orgy 494 okay so i
actually get the tomorrow off okay yeah
most people nowadays really go for the
english attack with Bishop e3 Queen d2
and so on okay know something entirely
different here huh that's a rare move
Knight b3 them and voluntary retreat so
what am I going to me I can just put
just them play a ravening on type of
setup but I won't know is actually
allowing bhai view ok so getting better
and better
so what is he going to play is playing
the most passive moves ever and then
wants to sacrifice with 95 probably that
seems to be the idea but okay I can
block the e-file and still have before
in reserve
ok
Jim rook i wonder if i should play rook
c8 or can also do this for a quick night
see form and also possibly
total isn't simply not reacting to
anything what I'm doing so Nyjah for is
interesting what is he doing then g3
looks that looks really terrible hmm but
maybe it's not committed it's not great
but maybe it's not like lost for words
but it looks bad can also take d3o i can
go before it's all pretty good hmm
okay okay hard to decide what to do so
okay i have queen bee 61 I can go here
first let's do this first so II five or
queen queen bee six it can probably play
Queenie to
you know I might can maybe I can just
take it for then it's a very weird
tactic but Queenie to Bishop b4 is that
possible but should be for Bishop before
night if 12 I don't see why not at the
moment let's take it
Bishop takes Knight takes Queen takes
Queen f2 is checkmate and Bishop takes
Knight takes Queen g4 the screen have to
check a king and 92 at least maybe
that's something better okay well here I
can take d three or go to a seven
probably to a seven keeping the pressure
on f2 can take on before maybe I'm yeah
that's possible
okay so i can to take here and just play
this position it's not my dad not
material down or anything and he's got a
very weird position there on the on the
King on the queenside and so maybe start
with this move I can still go to h6 but
I can play this intermediate attack so I
can't have a technical I really have to
go here yeah that's definitely true it's
a bit of a strange situation you for the
Knights ok g5 is not a threat night at
five is coming then
if I go Queen will be seven hey Scott
got 95 how weird is that so clip let's
go back gee 59 f five is good anyway
time morning hey let's do this I night
on age 6 this is not great it can become
a pretty good piece actually just has to
be re-routed here to e5 on my way or to
g5 keeping an eye on the night
I don't want to trade queens but I
probably have to i can go Quinn before
it sound better and I should have played
that much quicker actually so just a
good move
but that crank is a bit weak have to be
a bit cautious there and I'm not
stumbling into some back rank tricks you
know let's just try to ask a look-see I
just wanted to make sure that my back
rank is a bit save on Queen a one rupee
to was possible anyway may I should have
gone to d2 immediately I would have been
better check oxy to wipe ignite see to
what kind of moves that I didn't even
expect that one bit funny
no time
yeah i know i'm winning i think check
but i have no time absolutely no time my
dev three kings a bag I don't see a maid
check game draw it will see a maid and i
only have six seconds okay there the
engine says it's a draw k 93 was winning
okay had no time hey i'm in no time yeah
the probably problem was he played this
wiki he night see two more and i was
just totally i was basically pre moving
Roxy too because I thought he plays Roxy
to like everybody would but ok played
this move and ok I can play whatever and
win Quincy 1-5 and a couple of pawns up
and his position is just falling apart
him it was the problem is his keyhole
King cytisus is weak here in this
position very very weird very weird
position yeah I don't know but this
looks look too funny to not it will not
play the engine is just saying it's
equal I know not here I'm sorry once the
play night before not be sure before so
what what is it that the engine is
suggesting your age 5 interesting how
yeah okay that's that's definitely
that's definitely an idea and just push
the H porn it gives like- 1.6 that's a
bit much now but it's very nice you know
let's say something like this an H for
my rook is doing a very good job
and here it gives equal now but is very
complicated very complicated position
deputy I'm better right you know like
minus one flex position is very active
f5 was interesting here Jerry difficult
difficult to play they also like that
one but it's here they're probably a
couple of mistakes but yeah it's funny
am I was just expecting Brooks e2 not
night situ and looks it to tell taking
it's just cilia it doesn't make any
sense and Here I am okay yeah that's
that's pure pure tactical madness 93
already wins here but okay I have no
time whatsoever and the way it went with
the draw is probably not the no not an
unfair result I mean okay well thanks
for watching